I'm gonna tell you about a new video
that reason just made its about how to
make your own handgun using some very
simple tools and parts you can buy
online we're not even going to think
about posting it on YouTube so a couple
of months ago after the March for our
lives rally YouTube said that they were
no longer going to allow users to post
videos that contain instructions on
manufacturing a firearm the video and
its accompanying article are part of a
package of stories and reasons burn
after reading issue this includes a
bunch of how to's including how to bake
pot brownies how to launder Bitcoin how
to pick the lock on handcuffs and how to
hire an escort the whole issue is a
celebration of free speech and our way
of documenting how utterly futile all
kinds of prohibitions can be the reason
we made a video showing how easy it is
to DIY a Glock is because we wanted to
show how the First Amendment reinforces
and backs up the Second Amendment
basically if a bunch of journalists can
build a handgun in their kitchen we can
certainly assume that it will be too
hard to keep guns out of the hands of
motivated criminals the question is once
we've made the video if YouTube prevents
us from uploading it have they violated
our First Amendment rights YouTube of
old days was this amazing thing that's
become the live the digital library of
alexandria of the internet carl kisara
is the host of in range TV which is a
weekly youtube show about guns they used
to survive on ad revenue until YouTube
started D monetizing content hi I'm
Dennis Prager and welcome to my home and
last October the conservative video
production shop Prager University
sued YouTube saying that they had
restricted the audience for their
content and alleging that the company
was unlawfully censoring its educational
videos and discriminating against its
right to freedom of speech here's the
thing YouTube is a private platform and
there is nothing in the First Amendment
or the second that requires them to run
our gun video reason can turn down
articles for any cause that we choose we
can do it because we don't like the
color of the author's hair we don't like
the font she use in her pitch email we
do not violate a single constitutional
amendment when we do that don't get me
wrong I wish that YouTube would run our
video it's awesome
but equally awesome is their right and
ours not your own content we
like right now there are people in
YouTube and in Facebook and other parts
of this oligarchy of corporate
controller of the internet that have
decided for whatever reason to use this
concept of community standards to set
fire to books in the Library of
Alexandria Carl Kerr sarda is right that
YouTube is the closest thing that we
have to the Library of Alexandria still
doesn't mean they have to run our video
whether you like pornhub or big
pornography is a blight I understand
once YouTube made it impossible for
kisara to make money on their platform
he just started posting his content to
other platforms including pornhub
psychological perspective versus yes
there might be issues with pornography
depending on your belief system access
to the megaphone of your choice is not a
right protected by the Constitution and
YouTube is hardly the first to test this
in 1972 a teachers union president who
was running for state legislature
actually sued the Miami Herald insisting
that they run an editorial he had
written after they attacked him in their
pages the Supreme Court correctly ruled
that ordering a newspaper to run an
editorial is a violation of the First
Amendment
after all a newspaper is more than a
passive receptacle are you convinced
after going through this long process
and and digging into the suit that
Google's motives are ideological there
was no other possibility Prager
University argued that YouTube isn't
entitled to the same editorial
discretion as the Miami Herald because
it advertises itself is a platform for
free expression that's committed to
fostering a community where everyone's
voice can be heard
a federal judge thankfully dismissed the
Praeger lawsuit rejecting the company's
argument that YouTube is comparable to a
government entity and thus must be open
access a slew of other judges have
arrived at the same conclusion YouTube
deserves exactly the same latitude that
those judges gave to the Miami Herald in
the 1970s and that reason in choice
today and that's one of the things that
our gun video is celebrating if YouTube
doesn't want us to post it to their site
they're lost
we'll just post it to another platform
that's what the free and open Internet
is about so if you want to see our video
you can head over to reason.com
or pornhub and see how to make your very
own unregistered firearm